wir sind heute in österreich genau
genommen im wunderschönen graz und bei
uns ist matthias wir reden heute über
worte im österreichischen deutsch die
wir deutschen nicht verstehen weil wir
reden ja was der eigene sprache und wir
verstehen ja alles was er sagt das ist
richtig die österreicher die lernen
hochdeutsch in der schule sie sehen
hochdeutsch im fernsehen zum beispiel
aber umgekehrt ist es nicht so wir haben
fast gar kein kontakt zum
österreichischen dialekt und deswegen
wenn wir deutschen österreich kommen
verstehen wir ganz oft überhaupt nicht
worüber geredet und das ist mir heute
mehr aus genau matthias hat zehn worte
mitgebracht losgeht
jung
matthias ich bin schon ganz gespannt auf
dein erstes wort ich kenne die worte
sich und musste jetzt raten was die
heißen
okay wir versuchen die worte so zu sagen
dass du mensch ahnung hast was ich sage
wie sorg aber wir fangen glaube an das
erste wort ist cremig griff ich dass ich
weiß nicht mal ob das nun ist oder wer
es ist also eine person konkret genau
bestimmt böse oder grummelig so na na na
na das gegenteil nämlich total süß und
wir sagen das motto bist so greve als
gespannt dann ist das schon sagen ja ich
habe den grat sprechen sie nicht so
dialekten mäßigen gratis nur relativ ein
schöner sport also wie schwer es
manchmal relativ eine sprache das
nächste woche tun ist sie gieren
gespannt hören dass ich werde
wahrscheinlich kein einziges wort
verstehen regieren sie ihren genossen
werden soll wer ganz genau
ist das sowas wie sezierend nagorny wird
die halt gerne wieder regieren mit meine
worte gott so schrecklich mein enkelkind
zitiert wie oft das bedeutet wieder
ärgern oder kratzen kratzen das ist das
wo sie ihren spaß machen oder das wieder
ärgern so viel spass und meine kleine
schwester wäre manchmal regieren aber
ärgernis aufwiesen so negativ belegt und
sie gehen ist
ist wie sie lustig das negativ belegt
ist wieso wir deutschen das sagen
deswegen das hat mit dem grund wollen
wir einem schnupfen dauernd arretiert
damit steht das mitgebrachte wie es wäre
ja überhaupt dann könne man aber dass
verwendet man jetzt wir in so einem
spiel
steiner das schreiben schreiben
schreiben jetzt hier auf zum reha
klassische also für arbeit ich nicht
mehr an
ich habe heute soviel arbeit ich könnte
mich an heute gern heißt weinen
warum hast du halt so weil er dirigiert
habe als nächstes mikroskopie / aus
das ist bestimmt vogel scheiße ja aber
ist halt bedeutung der werkausschuss
ganz lustiges lappalie woche mit den da
ist dann hat man werden muss den
autobots dutzend autos beschädigt
aber es geht in wirklichkeit um ein
ganzer kleinigkeit als wenn du sagst
wegen dem lehel schaffte es wegen der
scheiße von einer lehrherr wegen einer
kleinigkeit trägst du jetzt auf die sich
ihr die mission lehrer erschossen du
fängst du zum realen also genauso denn
bei uns ist dass er wegen so einem
scheiß sagen wir mit so einem scheiß
york ein ampelsystem sein lächeln
schafften es macht so ein bisschen
klarer und kleber ist es wirklichkeit
aber nicht zum grantig werden die frage
was ist grant scherben gerade scherben
kam genau grantig zu tun
ja also grantig ist sauer ja genau sie
weiß gar nicht ob so richtig deutsches
wort dafür gibt aber es kommt sehr nahe
an diese wörter dann ja genervt
genau kann sich sagen wir in deutschland
aber 20 jahre genau er sagt er meine
mutter als ich generation sagte grant
scherben
wir nennen so zusammen person die
grantige fragen wie was bist du für kant
scherben
das nächste wort ist schnack all das was
mit schnacken
was ist schnacken schnacken verwenden
wir gar nichts aber schnell schnappen
nichts zu tun
also ist nicht ein schnack nach das
verstehe ich etwas gefunden was ich ihn
verstehe ja schnacke irgendeine ahnung
ein nackenschlag
was hatten griffen war ihm schmackhaft
aber schlag auf schlag alles schluckauf
und wir sagen niemand denkt werden die
jetzt einen schluckauf genau genau das
nächste wort ist kraxelt kraxeln kraxeln
ist tatsächlich ein wort das ich kenne
aber ich weiß nicht ob es das gleiche
bedeutet und zwar in also in unserem
verständnis ist das mühsam einen berg
hinauf gehen oder so oder so wie
bergsteigen war sie aber nicht so ganz
richtig bergsteigen ja werden das ist es
ist klettern hat aber nichts mit mühsam
zum brand sondern nur konstant baum ganz
mutig und flott hoch packen wir's an den
bahnhof praxisklasse als klein geboren
haben wir das nochmal formation ihren
kriegt er wahnhaft es ist ganz sicher
ganz gern trucks um so zum ausgleich von
der schule oder so das nächste gott ist
groß das chaos league ist und wir sollen
vor ort brügge
ja ich weiß das heißt das heißt als
regen
ja ja und noch was zu essen richtig es
ist das nicht diese wurst und käse
genauer käsekrainer das ist wenn man so
rein sticht wie eiterbeulen die
aufplatzen oder käse aus gehabt das ist
der gag lecker wir sagen in deutschland
nicht gruselig aber das will ich auch
sagte und sagt anna kraus lediglich so
richtig eklige sword das habe ich schon
gedacht als ich zum allerersten mal nach
wien gekommen
ja ist der v6 wort aber es ist auch
richtig gute wurst
ich werde das wort also ich war das wort
immer noch nie verwendet ja genau
also wir sagen jetzt wünscht allen
bestellern käse kerner aber nicht viel
bringen muss ich als ich kenne leute das
immer sagen aber es wird immer kälter
und das ist sofort nummer 9 mathias
meistens so kann und das ist so ein cars
cars käse richtig ihren zusammenhang
sagte das so sagen ja oder bescheuert
sein mag es ja wir sagen auch das ist
käse sagt glaube ich auch er die
generation meiner eltern
spannend aber das heißt ja auch auf
niederländisch käse wirklichkeit ja wir
sind kann es für käse und superstars ich
glaube ich noch zwei wochen länger hier
bleiben wirklich aus
ja es ist so arg arg s hier freute so
auf wie nie zurecht nach berlin zu
besuch kommen
ob die herren mit sprache werde ich
schon immer doch die arbeitssprachen bei
spruch so das letzte wort er sich hoffe
dass ich noch mal eins verstehe
schauen wir mal das letzte wort ist heiß
heißer im und schlüssel bringen das sei
so ganz genau
letzte woche nur lebkuchen haissl baut
erfolgreich andere anderem zusammenhang
verwendet habe
es kommt von kleinem haus häuschen hasel
und das kind ist kleine häuschen one
früher kommt es dass verwenden das immer
noch für toilette sei so verständlich
wie das gibt s doch jetzt seid ihr dran
liebe leute wir wollen von euch wissen
welche worte habt ihr gekannt oder ja
schon kennengelernt im deutschunterricht
oder durch euer leben in österreich
schreibt uns unbedingt einen kommentar
dazu
und ihr könnt jetzt in der abwehr
ist halt noch mehr österreichische worte
kennenlernen wie matthias ja jetzt wie
die adventszeit wäre ja einen kleinen
österreichisch deutsch adventskalender
auf meinem instagram veranstalten und
jeden tag eines meiner lieblings
österreichischen worte vorstellen
das entspannt weil da kann ich auch noch
was lernen wichtig genau freue mich
rechts vorbei ist eigentlich für uns
auch gemacht uns doch richtig extra für
euch wie ist dein instagram account metz
unterstrich super social einfach auf
instagram eingeben und dann kommt man
jeden tag ein neues österreichisches
sofort lernen den link zu matthias in
servern findet ihr in der infobox folgt
dem auf instagram da könnt ihr dann
jeden tag ein österreichisches wort lern
und wenn ihr lust habt noch interaktive
übungen zu machen an eurem computer hat
zu der grammatik zu den worten wollt
benutzern werdet einen patch in
abonniert easy german und drückt die
klingel dann werdet ihr immer
benachrichtigt wenn ein neues video
kommt wir gehen jetzt noch über den
christkindlmarkt ja ich freue mich